salut vous connaissez peut-être ce décor
et ce château il ya quelques semaines
femmes et nous avons tourné une partie
de cluedo géant ici avec un mix n pierre
cross dock seven y avait émis ltr et
céline h également
alors cette vidéo vous avez énormément
plu enfin je suppose soit pas se mentir
je tourne cette vidéo là aussi le même
jour si vous aviez raté cette partie
épique vous pouvez cliquer sur le lien
qui est au dessus de moi mais si vous
l'aviez raté ça veut dire quelque chose
c'est à dire qu'il ya un problème donc
pour ne plus rater deux vidéos vous
pouvez vous abonner et activer la cloche
aujourd'hui on est sur un autre délire
avec une vidéo interactive j'avais fait
ça aussi pour la vidéo du midi dans un
disque est games interactive j'avais
fait aussi un test de mentalisme
interactif les liens sont dans la
description
aujourd'hui il part sur un cloud au lit
car interactif c'est au dessus tout ça
la vidéo que vous êtes en train de
visionner la maintenant celle ci tout de
suite où je parle c'est la seule
référence et sur youtube c'est la seule
public donc si vous les mettez un like
n'hésitez pas à le faire ici maintenant
si vous voulez mettre un commentaire au
fur à mesure de la vidéo n'hésitez pas à
le déposer ici parce que bon c'est mieux
pour l'algorithme et c'est mieux pour le
référencement les hôtels seront non
répertoriés elle ne compte pas alors
est-ce que vous êtes prêts pour le
premier plus d'eau interactif du youtube
game je ne vous entends pas et c'est
normal c'est parti en fait quand quand
je dis c'est parti il faut cliquer sur
commencer la vignette kiala et si elle
n'apparaît pas aller dans la description
donc c'est parti